guys it's so good to connect with both
of you uh it's good to see you colin
and forrest and first of all uh platinum
this is this is massive this the
announcement just came through how did
you find
out and did you get to party and
actually celebrate the whole thing
we found out it was platinum like a
while back um
which like it doesn't take away from the
excitement like when we did find out i
think our managers had texted us that it
went like platinum in a few countries
and we were like oh my gosh like this is
so insane
and i know it took riaa like a
like a while to like certify it but like
even when like the riaa certification
came through like
that's what felt like really the moment
and then like
sadly enough like we were all like
managers me for us like we were all
in different places but like it didn't
take away from the fact that like it's
such a really really cool accolade to
have and
it's just like a really cool thing to
know that like what we're doing is like
working think i think we were talking
about the instagram post for
gold like yeah like post on instagram
that went gold
and they responded like hey you guys
know it like went platinum
no way is that what happened yeah
yeah and it's interesting because i have
two girls and they're walking around the
house doing tick-tock and this stuff and
like
what is happening and i hear your song
sunday best
feeling good like i should and that's
when i discovered your music i'm like
these guys are
really good when did you know your music
was such a massive hit on tick tock
um managers filled this in yeah it was
kind of this like rolling thing because
like
we don't really know too much about tick
tock but um
they like our managers would update us
on it and they'd
talk about like oh there's this many
today and there's this many day and then
it almost like
became like it kept growing and growing
to the point where
we like almost like didn't even ask like
they'd be like oh yeah like a hundred
thousand tick tocks for me today and
we're like
insane yeah do you know the dance
no i don't know i have no idea wait wait
you guys haven't learned the dance
funny story we were in oh gosh where
were we in charlotte
i think we were in charlotte doing a
meet and greet back when touring was
still a thing
and uh i think like some of our fans
came up and they wanted us to do the
dance and we were like oh man
we have no idea how to do that so and
then like they wanted to teach us
another dance and we were just
it's like there's so many movements and
stuff it's really hard to like teach
someone about confidence you know it's
like
all of this stuff i know
but you know amazing canadian did a
dance for your song justin bieber i mean
that's a that's a big deal who saw it
first was it you calling it for us
we probably saw it at like the same time
yeah i i think our men we have a group
text their managers that's pretty active
and i think like they sent it and like
i know a bunch of our friends have been
dming us they're like dude
like everybody i know would you ever
want to collaborate with justin bieber
yeah i mean yeah i mean it he'd have to
be like really
into it not i mean not to say like he
wouldn't but like
we're all about like if we are to work
with someone outside of surfaces
we want them to be just as passionate
about what we're doing as they are
because like that's the only
way it's going to be natural and not
forced
and everything in our growth
has been like a natural non
gimmicky decision i guess or at least
the things that are working and so
um we just want to maintain the heart
and the soul of what we are
i love that talking about being natural
i mean you're working with sir elton
john
like how where what who manager
like you're you're singing with elton
john like i
my mind is blown away how did that even
happen during isolation
yeah um so we had actually uh
had kind of the the concept of the song
already done and we have a lot like i
mean in colonized heads and our voice
memos we probably have like 15 20 songs
that are like decent songs they're
sitting there and um that was just the
one that kind of popped up we were
actually in this room and uh we
kind of knocked the whole thing out in a
day and recorded it right here
um and then we had this the demo was
pretty much done
and so usually we'll send like a demo
into our managers and be like hey like
what do you guys think yeah
well this is awesome like it's really
light and upbeat and um
they said hey would you guys consider
getting a feature on this song
like you're you know sunday best is
doing well you're at you're kind of a
point and like it makes sense from like
a business
stance we're like you know if it if it
is natural maybe
like let's let's you you can send it out
we'll see like we're not going to say no
and so they sent it out and uh sure
enough elton john responded and was like
hey
i love this song i want to be a part of
it and that response is what
kind of pushes us over the edge like
okay and i mean even if even if it
wasn't like
i don't did you even believe it like
you're singing with elton john
found out we found that over at facetime
and the room that
horse is sitting in and we were both
like i think forrest still has videos
that we're just losing her mind i know i
need to i need to like post some of the
videos
i literally have called for action
and the song is so beautiful too it's so
uplifting
what influenced that song you said you
had all these songs in place but what
was it particularly about
this song learned to fly that made you
feel like
this was the right sign to release right
now i remember
we were bouncing ideas we were in the
um the prac what is it called the
we're setting up for uh gosh i can't
talk late night with seth meyers the
rehearsal okay
okay okay studio in l.a
uh practicing for seth meyers i think it
was gonna be in like two weeks
and we were sitting on the couch in this
rehearsal studio and like just
bouncing off ideas and we're like man
this is this is a cool one but like we
never
it was it was on a laptop and we were
just like typing and
just feeling out of hook and then kind
of pocketed it maybe did a voice memo or
two and then
brought it back to forrest's place maybe
like a month or two later because like
when we're writing songs or we're
preparing a song we don't
like oh this is a good one let's just
find a studio right now and go record it
like it has
kind of timing it comes down to feeling
it comes down to like environment like
we usually record when it's daylight
outside and like
it's more sunnier vibes and it's more
upbeat rather than night time
um so we kind of like played it patient
and then like
it was kind of weird because like the
the pandemic kind of revealed itself
yeah you came back to force's house like
right before pandemic and we're like man
like
what better time to really put thought
and care into finishing
this really special song than right now
when people could move there was an
element of like
if not now then when like this is the
right time for the song
and i was just saying i could feel your
passion and the the amount of work and
time you put into your music and you do
it little you do it slower
and you think it through and the fact
that you're releasing your third album
horizons which is a massive hit for a
lot of people already getting great
vibes for it
have you ever kind of sat back and
reflected
the success you're having i mean you
dm'd into colin and
you did voice memos and now you're
living your passion
like you're at a point where you can say
you're successful
have you had a chance to kind of reflect
on that i feel like we reflect on it
every day
like they're like every day that i walk
into a
a room dedicated to music where i mean
it used to be
a college desk that was for work and i
had the laptop going and colin had some
stuff and we
kind of gathered some gear but to have
like an actual like
you know studio stuff going on and like
make a career out of it and have people
show up for tour and
yeah it's it's every day is like what we
get to do this
and people are paying money for us to do
this we get to feed ourselves off this
is
never take it for granted like it feels
like you know when family and friends
like they get to ask like oh you know
like what are like what's your passion
like what are you doing after college
like what are you doing
like i'm chasing music but like it's not
like a you know
we're hopping on youtube like ripping a
beat and like doing something for five
seconds
like we've been doing this for years and
it finally came to
we've never been more grateful to have
it and
be completely love in love with what we
do every single day and such a special
thing